the pandemic has certainly strained all  of us more americans are trying to find  jobs and they're also sometimes trying  to find  food however the challenge of the moment  has also inspired more volunteering and  we've seen that all across southern  nevada as well  organizations in the u.s say they've  noticed more young people especially  taking part in charity  a lot of us just have all this free time  and energy that we want to  spend and we realize that helping others  during a time when people really need it  is a great way  to maybe direct that energy giving back  and also as it turns out be good for  your health  research shows volunteering helps people  stay physically active  and mentally active as well